pas de négociation possible pour abroger
les lois de la république le ministère d
outre mer restent intransigeants face
aux opposants au passage un ter qui se
sont introduits de force dans l'enceinte
du conseil régional de guadeloupe ils y
ont passé la nuit et occupent d'ailleurs
toujours l'hémicycle et manifestants qui
ont obtenu une réunion avec le président
de région demande à l'état de se joindre
à la table des négociations pour
discuter des problèmes à l'origine de la
crise sociale que connaît l'île les
manifestants ont fait savoir qu'ils
occuperaient les lieux jusqu'à la
reprise et pourparlers interrompus il ya
deux semaines écoutez philippe bélair
secrétaire général de la cgt cgt
guadeloupe nous avertissions de sept
mois qu'il y ait un souci que nous
allons vers un problème est qu'il y aura
certainement une explosion sociale si ce
problème là n'est pas arrivé il ce
problème là là la loi sur l'obligation
vaccinale
l'a fait émerger
il fait que la population est excédée
par le fait que les politiciens en
général n'écoute pas ne sont pas allés
coûte de bcg se demandent maintenant
nous attendons qu'ils que l'état en
dehors de ces déclarations et publics
fassent un effort
de responsabilité puisque il s'agit de
bien de sa d'être responsables dans ces
cas-là action il n'est pas violent elle
et elle est symbolique notre action
n'est pas violente notre option est les
politiques parce que nous sommes venus
là où il doit y avoir la négociation
nécessaire pour régler